(comical music)
Well, it's time to share
some home-cooked pasta
with someone I don't get
to see enough these days,
Andy Richter.
Hey Conan, Thanks for having me over.
I'm super excited to have you here,
sitting at the same table.
'Cause today, I've made one
of the most labor-intensive,
but rewarding pasta
dishes ever, the timpano.
Wait, is that the pasta dish
from the movie "Big Night?"
That's right.
It's a massive pasta drum,
stuffed with Genoa salami,
meatballs, eggs and cheese,
and topped with thick,
delicious Prego pasta sauce!
Yes, it took me three days to make it!
Wait, wait, wait.
Did you say Prego pasta sauce?
Yes, so this timpano must
weigh about six pounds.
It's such a thick sauce.
Lemme just lift it up and show you.
You're going to love seeing--
No, no, no, no, don't bother.
Just, you know, just slide
me over that jar of Prego
and I'll just drink it
straight from the jar.
That's plenty for me.
Sure.
I mean, this did take
me a long time to make.
Nah, I'll be good with
just the jar of Prego.
Oh, just the Prego, okay.
Here you go, ol' pal.
Ah, thank you.
Oh, could I get a straw too, please?
Yeah, I happen to have a
giant straw right here.
(slide whistle whoops)
(sighs) Oh man, let's do this!
Okay, Andy.
(Andy slurping)
You're sure you don't
want to try my timpano.
It's right here.
You can literally just lift it up.
Oh, that is so good.
I just felt a chunk of tomato
tickling my uvula going.
Thank you so much.
Hey, Prego!
Yeah, no duh, I can read the label.
No, Andy, Prego is Italian
for you're welcome.
Oh, okay.
Oh my God!
A squirrel is eating my timpano!
[Announcer] Prego, It
means you're welcome.